NFL Christmas gifts have begun and
Trevor Lawrence showed up for his o
lineman we've seen Aaron Rogers give his
guy scooters we saw Zach Wilson do the
same thing and so did Josh Allen except
he customized them but Lawrence really
channel the Florida lifestyle and he got
his guys golf carts while he gifted a
form of transportation other QBs in the
past have gone for a different vibe one
year Patrick Mahomes gifted his o
lineman tailor made golf clubs Jaylen
Herz got his guys Louis Vuitton bags
which is where this hilarious photo
originated and it's not just QBs who get
their guys presents former bills and now
Colts wide receiver Isaiah McKenzie
gifted his wide receiver teammates
arcade game machines last year with over
9,000 games installed